we are taking your calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0
47 50 sort of a different Friday show
today no audience questions no classic
interview doing more new stories than we
normally do because I was away for a
couple of days in LA doing a few
different appearances including with Joe
Rogan let's go to oh you know what Alex
is on the phone Alex who interrupts is
on the phone that's how we have them
labeled and we haven't heard from Alex
since January so what's going on Alex
hey David hey I my question is in
regards to Susan's United I know you
touch on it a few times better so
there's no limit to how much you can
make how much money you can make on
political speech in German Washington
Post did a Super Bowl ad that was 5
million dollars so there's no limit
there hold on a second so wait let me
see if I understand there's no limb I'm
trying to understand there's no limit to
how much you can make on political
speech because the Washington Post spent
5 million dollars on an ad I don't know
that I understand what you mean
obviously means they make millions of
dollars yeah it's a big corporation they
only make a lot of money yeah ok I agree
with that they make the Washington Post
makes money so what's wrong with
spending as much as you want on
political speech I have no idea how the
two things are even related
citizens united is right yes you know
the background of it
I mean inform me if you think there's an
element of it I don't understand well
they want to limit how much people can
spend before an election who wants to
limit but the people who are against
citizens you know that people that took
United to course right there are people
who want to level the playing field when
it comes to political spending in order
to make our system more like those of
other countries yes that's true there's
people who think that money in politics
is not
good force go on okay well why because
it has a corrupting influence you we
already have a system where the rich and
corporations have an outsized amount of
influence not because they necessarily
have better ideas but because they are
able to peddle that influence and use
lobbyists and political donations and
PACs to get politicians to pay hold on
I'm in the middle of xsplit do you want
to hear my explanation or not Alex okay
we already have a system where even
though everybody gets quote one vote the
desires and the policies that would
benefit the vast majority of people are
not taken as seriously by our elected
officials as are the desires of large
corporations and rich people because of
their ability to use money in politics
to get what they want to be the
priorities of our elected officials and
people who want to even the playing
field want to even the playing field of
influence as well okay well you know
voters they want to know who's going to
be good for the country so yeah you know
all this is information you know if you
want somebody to win you have to show
that they're going to be good for the
country who has to show why can't you
why can't you send that information to
as many people as you want it would be
great if everybody could send all of
that information to as many people as
they want the problem is rich Corp rich
people and big corporations have the
money to send whatever messages they
want regardless of whether they are
accurate or not and poor people middle
income people small business owners who
might have the exact same desire to
reach just as many people can't do it
merely because they don't have enough
money right that's that's speech you
know it costs money to to speak you try
and reach as many people as you can yeah
you know right so what's your point you
so let me see if I understand Alex you
just
you just think unlimited political
spending is fine it sounds like yes okay
all right good so we disagree we just
disagree about that all right thanks
Alex I appreciate the phone call of
information David I'm not afraid of
people okay he's not afraid of
information got it all right just so
people know there's a delay on the
hang-up so how do I actually did want to
hear the rest of what he was saying
there but you can't undo you can't
unring the Bell once I hit the hang-up
button